Welcome to this week on "Distributed Software Development".
Distributed Software Development means the process of software development, which we
all know and love; but involving individuals who are distributed in different physical
locations, potentially all around the world.
This week we're going to review several software tools that I think many of you will already
be familiar with from the 169 course.
Thus this week is a bit of a refresher in some ways. Next week we'll connect up more
strongly to team practices.
Although as we go through I will do my best to mention the connections each tool or concept
has to distributed team management.
Anyhow, many of these things we're going to talk about this week are just as valuable
for the opposite of "Distributed Software Development",
that is: "Centralised Software Development"
By Centralized Software Development we mean what goes on in your startup or your company
where you have a room, or a floor, full of people.
All the team are there together and they can quickly jump into a meeting room and discuss
what they're doing.
Also, they can bump into each other over the water cooler and so on.
So anyhow the software development techniques we're looking at this week are incredibly
valuable in whatever way your team is set up.
Several of them are key concepts from the Engineering Software as a Service course that
I want to pull out, partly because it's good to have a refresher on them;
partly because they are the kind of things that many MOOC students get stuck on,
but also because they are critical components of working effectively in distributed teams.
So I believe that having all of these concepts clear in your mind will be extremely helpful.
And while some of them are very valuable in centralised software development settings,
I think they're *particularly* valuable in distributed settings.
So let's just give you a quick overview of what's coming up, we've got a series of videos,
and first of all we're going to talk about user stories:
That's the process of ensuring that the work you do actually meets customer needs, rather
than just being what you think is cool.
This might seem like a sort of wishy washy thing, but I think the really clever person,
the really really clever person, works out not how they can use a set of technical tools
in order to solve a problem; they work out what the problem really is.
In particular they work out what's the minimum intervention that would satisfy the customer.
Sometimes the best solution is one where we say "actually we've worked out there isn't
a problem here and thank you very much",
and you get paid a large consulting fee for having worked out a way of solving things
with slight modifications to existing systems and processes.
However, more often than not, people will want custom solutions and so then you'll be
collaborating with others while using your toolkit of different coding skills and knowledge
of different frameworks.
Still, the key thing is that you have to get the user stories sorted out up front; sorting
out the wheat from the chaff so to speak.
You've got to work out what the customer really needs, even when they aren't sure themselves
and that's what the process of developing user stories is all about.
Then there's user stories versus chores.
Chores are bits of infrastructure work that have got to be done; and you need to track
and coordinate them.
So that's the start of this week: user stories and chores.
What we're trying to do here is represent a bit of the flow that you might follow working
through a real project, which is for example, on inception, you will be starting with user
stories.
Then having developed those user stories with the customers and other stakeholders you'd
be also realizing "aha these various chores have got to be done too".
And then you'll say right okay well we'll put off some of these chores.
Here let's just start working on the first two user stories we think that are key for
our MVP or Minimum Viable Product.
And then you can start work and you might actually start coding with, let's say, Cucumber
or RSpec doing an acceptance test and then even getting down to the unit test level.
This acceptance-test/unit-test cycle is also very important; this process of getting red
acceptance tests, red unit tests and then going green is absolutely key and we'll go
through that in more detail this week.
It's absolutely essential for quality control.
There's also the process of communicating with the team through the codebase itself.
I believe, along with Armando and many others, that the documentation is not necessarily
worth the paper it's written on.
What we want is *live* documentation, which is your acceptance tests and your unit tests
that explain what's happening in the system.
That's just absolutely essentially and creates documentation that can be verified by running
it against the code.
So that's important for quality control and communication with the rest of the team.
Again whether you're distributed or centralized it doesn't make too much difference,
but again I hope you can sense the arrangement of this week's materials reflects the flow
you might have in a serious project.
Version control then comes in, given that you want to be able to undo people's mistakes
(especially your own).
Then you further develop the user stories, the acceptance and unit tests etc.
Even the user stories themselves should be going into version control.
Anyhow, a really good understanding of version control, and how to use distributed version
control systems like GitHub
(that's systems that allow every team member to have access to the codebase)
is absolutely absolutely essential these days.
Furthermore, many of us will also be deploying to the cloud, through Git or other version
control systems.
So once you've got "version one" of your system you'll want to get that up in the cloud.
Thus we'll review the Heroku "Platform as a Service" and then finally this other concept
which we think is critically important, which is this idea of "spiking".
"Spiking" refers to quickly developing a prototype that you're then going to throw away afterwards.
I think back in the day as, I say in the actual video itself, that was what everybody did
all the time.
There were almost no tests and all code was one big spike.
You might say shouldn't we avoid that at all costs, but I think it's good to have a name
for it.
Then when you're talking to members of your team; or as we're talking with students in
169 we can talk about "oh right what you were doing there was a bit of a spike".
"Now let's stop that and go back and do a really rigorous acceptance-test/unit-test
cycle as we move forward"
So that's the overview for this week.
I hope you find all this of some interest and that they're nice refreshers.
Apologies in advance that I haven't been able to re-record all of this week's videos.
I have managed to add full transcripts for all of them, which I hope will help make them
more comprehensible.
As you'll be able to tell, the upcoming videos were recorded somewhat off the cuff and a
year or two ago.
There are other things I'd like to update, such as to the latest RSpec 3 syntax in the
acceptance-test/unit-test video,
but I think the concepts are still sufficiently clear and so at the moment I am prioritizing
completing subtitles for all the videos in the upcoming weeks.
Also in some of these videos, I do go into some live code examples, so those videos do
run a bit longer.
I think those are valuable in that you can see me making mistakes and recovering from
them, which is kind of the core skill.
It's really important for learning that we understand making mistakes is natural and
human and we all do it, and it is how we learn.
Anyhow, please do feel free to watch as much as or as little as you prefer.
If you took the course recently and you're working with all these tools and techniques
regularly you may say "right, I kind of know this stuff already".
Obviously it's entirely up to you whether you watch the videos and do the little quizzes
at the end,
but what is required if you want to get the certificate is this week's assignment on Github
and Heroku and working with Git;
just to make sure you're on the tip top of those skills.
These are things which I think are very very important; both for working with distributed
teams and of course for the ESaaS MOOC.
Okay, so, I hope you enjoy this week and I look forward to continue making your acquaintance
in the slack chat; it really is great to be meeting so many of you there.
Alright bye for now.